Let's start talking about the efficiency
of this algorithm with a new example.
Here we have an array with eight
elements and we're going to try and
find the number ten.
Okay, so
we'll want to start in the middle.
This problem is a little bit weird
because there's an even number of
elements in this array.
So we could either start with four or
five really.
When you're designing your algorithm,
you need to decide from the start
whether you're going to
err on the lower side or
the higher side when you hit this
weird case of having no real middle.
I'm going to go ahead and
err on the lower side and
start with the number four.
Just like before, we'll check
whether our number is bigger or
smaller than the one in the middle.
And since our number is bigger,
now we only need to look at
the second half of the array.
Again, we have an even number
of elements in our array, so
we're going to pick the number on the
left of the middle and start from there.
Okay, since ten is greater than six, yet
again we get to cut our array in
half and deal with just the top.
Yet again we have an even
number of elements, so
we're going to err on the lower side and
check there first.
Since ten is greater than
our middle element seven,
we're left with just
the last element now.
And now that we've checked the highest
element in the array and our number is
still bigger than it, we know that this
number doesn't exist and we can move on.
Since the time efficiency is really
just the number of steps you're going to
need, keeping track of each iteration
is going to help us figure it out.
In the past, we had to step
through every single element,
but here we're cutting the array in
half and only considering some elements.
So the efficiency isn't going
to end up being as big as O(n).
I've created a table so
we can take a good look at
the array size versus the number
of iterations of our algorithm.
As we just saw, we had to go through
our algorithm four times for
an array size of eight.
Again, we're talking
about worst case here.
I could have tried to put a number
in between all of these places and
on the outsides to figure
out what the worst case was.
Just to save your time,
I did that before recording this video.
In the process I also
discovered a trick here.
If you want to make sure you're
checking for the worst case,
you can pick an element that's bigger
than anything else in the array.
And when you hit this weird middle case,
always favor the lower side.
You should prove this to yourself so
you know that it works, but
just trust me on it for now.
Okay, so for an array size of eight,
we have worst case for iterations.
We can take the results
from the first example too.
There it took us three steps to find
something in an array of seven.
Hm, let's start thinking about
different array sizes now.
If you had an array size of one and
you were looking for an element, say 30,
it would always only take you one step
to see whether that element was in your
array or not.
Great, that means we can
add one to our table.
Let's say we have an array with two
elements in it and we're looking for
this number, 23.
Again, I'm taking
advantage of that trick.
I picked a number bigger than
the ones that were in the array.
And when I have that weird case, I'm
always going to favor the lower side.
And when my array has
an even number of elements,
I'm going to pick the number
that's on the left of the middle.
Since 23 is greater than 18,
I can check 21 now.
In just two steps I have my answer,
that 23 doesn't exist in this array.
Great, we can add two to the table now.
In the interest of time, I'm not going
to go through all of these examples.
You should definitely do them
yourself though to prove that
these results are true.
Okay, we're starting to get
a picture of our efficiency here.
I notice that four is half of eight, so
maybe our efficiency looks
something like this.
Again, keep in mind that
I'm approximating here.
Instead of counting the number of
overall steps in the algorithm,
I'm just counting the number of times
I'll need to run the algorithm,
in this case four when my n is eight.
Actually I don't know that this is
true since half of two isn't two,
and half of one isn't one.
That's too bad.
I really feel like two should
go in this efficiency somewhere
since I have to cut the array in half
every single time I run the algorithm.
Let me think about exactly
what that means for a second.
If I cut the array in half every
time I go through an iteration,
that means every time I double
the number of elements,
I need to do an extra iteration.
Actually, now that I think about it,
that actually looks true with
the results of my table.
Every time my array doubles in size,
it takes an extra iteration of
the algorithm to get through it.
Actually when I represent these as
exponents, I notice that the power
on top of the two is always one more
than the number of iterations it takes.
So maybe my efficiency
looks more like this.
The number of overall iterations
is going to increase every time
the exponent on the power
of two increases, and
of course it's only off by one.
How do I get some number or
expression that represents this,
the power of two exponent?
So this is what I'm starting with,
the number of elements in my array, and
I want to end up with this number,
the exponent.
Well, I remember some weird math
that I used to do a long time ago.
There was this thing called
a logarithm that let me express
this kind of function
in a different way.
Instead of saying this,
I could say log base 2 of 8 = 3, and
it means the same thing.
Okay, so this looks a little bit nicer.
I want to make a point to note that
you don't need to know a ton about how
logarithms work to understand this.
If you just understand the equations I
showed you before, you should be fine.
So we could actually use another
approximation to make this
look even nicer.
As I mentioned before,
adding a constant or
adding one doesn't really
change my efficiency very much.
Also, I don't really need to
say that this is log base 2.
In computer science it's actually pretty
safe to assume that your logs are in
base 2.
We often do things like cut
arrays in half or use binary.
So our logs are normally going to be in
base 2 instead of the typical base 10.
So this is the efficiency
that we end up with.
A little later on we'll
have some more tools.
So it'll be easier for
me to show you visually why
this efficiency makes sense.
There's one thing I want to make
very clear to you all right now.
When I was learning about efficiency,
it often seemed like people could
just jump to this conclusion.
They could just look at
the original problem and say,
of course this is log n.
However, after years
of being a developer,
I learned that that
really wasn't the case.
I found that there are three main ways
that people can get to this efficiency.
One of them is just by knowing
what binary search is,
having seen it before, and being able
to just memorize the efficiency and
spit it out when you see it again.
I highly recommend you just memorize
the efficiency of basic algorithms for
your interviews.
It'll make you seem really smart if
you can just spit out the efficiency
from the start.
However, if you're presented
with a new problem and
you don't know the efficiency
of the algorithm already,
you need to be able to
solve it on your own.
One way you can do that is with proofs.
I personally don't like proofs and
have never used them in an interview or
seen other people use
them in interviews.
If you want to learn how to make proofs,
you can look it up online and
go read research papers and
see other people step through that.
However, my goal is to teach you
the practical approach to this.
When you haven't seen
the algorithm already, and
you don't have time to whip up a proof
out of nowhere, making a results table
like this is actually one of
the best things you can do.
Creating a results table
helps you notice patterns and
helps you start thinking about
efficiency in terms of array size
versus the number of
iterations of your algorithm.
When I first started
learning about efficiency,
I needed tables like this
to see those patterns.
However, after using tables for a while,
I started to be able to see
the patterns on my own without them.
Now when I interview,
I know what types of patterns are common
like changes in the powers of two.
And now I solve problems way quicker and
there are very few problems that I can't
at least approach and try to solve.
The worst thing you can do in
an interview is say I've never seen this
algorithm before or I don't know
how to write a proof for it.
If you're down on your luck and you
really don't know what the answer is,
please make a results table and
try to figure it out.
Your commitment to solving the problem
is really going to impress your
interviewer.